Das ist wirklich eine Sensation.
Noch nie wurde ein so scharfes Bild von einem
Schwarzen Loch gemacht.
Und es ist nicht wie bisher vermutet das Schwarze
Loch im Zentrum unserer Milchstraße Sagittarius
A*.
Sondern ein ganz anderes.
Das zentrale Schwarze Loch in der fernen Galaxie
Messier 87, sechs Milliarden Sonnenmassen
schwer.
Größe 100 Miliarden Kilometer.
Eines der größten bekannten Schwarzen Löcher.
So groß ist der Ereignishorizont hinter dem
Licht und Materie verschwinden.
Aber sieht man davon etwas?
Wir lüften hier und jetzt das Geheimnis:
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Science-Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen zu einem ganz besonderen
Moment in der Wissenschaftsgeschichte.
Zeitgleich sechs simultane Pressekonferenzen.
Das will schon etwas heißen.
Nochmal kurz die Grundlagen: Eine grundlegende
Eigenschaft eines Schwarzen Loches hat quasi
jeder Gegenstand, sogar ein Atom, den Schwarzschildradius.1916
kam der deutsche Astronom Karl Schwarzschild
auf die Idee, dass es bei jeder Masse einen
kugelförmigen Horizont geben müsse, bei
dem die Gravitation so groß ist, dass nichts
mehr aus dieser Kugel entweichen kann.
Bei allem, was wir sehen können ist dieser
Radius so klein, dass die Außengrenze dieses
Radiuses, der Ereignishorizont so klein ist,
dass sich eben die Materie ausserhalb dieses
Horizonts befindet und damit sichtbar ist.
Bei der Sonne beträgt dieser Schwarzschildradius
zum Beispiel drei Kilometer.
Sie hat eine Masse von zwei Quintillionen
Kilogramm, da ist er genauso groß.
Würde also die Masse der Sonne auf eine Größe
unter diesem Radius zusammenstürzen, dann
würde ein Mini-Schwarzes Loch entstehen.
Das geht aber nicht, da ihr Eigengewicht nicht
groß genug ist, um die Kräfte, die gegen
die Gravitation wirken zu überwinden.
Bei Sternen, die aber deutlich schwerer als
die Sonne sind passiert das.
Wenn am Ende die Fusion zum Erliegen kommt
und sie als Supernova explodieren und dann
mehr als die dreifache Sonnenmasse übrig
bleibt, ist deren eigenes Gewicht so stark,
dass die Gravitation, die Krümmung der Raumzeit
gemäß der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie
sie zu einem Schwarzen Loch zusammenstürzen
läßt.
Auch hier nochmal kurz zur Erinnerung.
Mass zieht Licht an.
Da Licht aber eine feste Geschwindigkeit hat,
kann es nicht beschleunigt werden.
Stattdessen muss sich die Raumzeit krümmen.
Das Ergebnis: Gravitation.
Und um so stärker sie ist, desto weniger
kommen andere Kräfte gegen sie an, zum Beispiel
die in einem Atomkern.
Man kann sich das so vorstellen, dass die
Gravitation so stark ist, dass auf unsere
Erde übertragen Berge in sich zusammenstürzen,
wir in die Erde gesogen werden und es immer
und immer dichter wird, dadurch die Kräfte
noch stärker werden, weil sich die Masse
auf eine noch kleinere Kugel verdichtet und
am Schluss…. ja am schluss.
Forschungsteams weltweit vermuten einen unendlich
kleinen punkt im Zentrum eines Schwarzen Loches.
Und was absolut irre ist, wahrscheinlich gibt
es auch im Zentrum von Galaxien und wahrscheinlich
sogar allen Galaxien so ein Schwarzes Loch,
nur ist es riesig, absolut gigantisch und
enthält die Masse von Millionen Sonnen oder
Milliarden.
Ein supermassereiches Schwarzes Loch.
Im Zentrum unserer Milchstrasse, da haben
wir ein solches Schwarzes Loch gefunden.
Um das Zentrum unserer Milchstrasse rasen
nämlich Sterne mit einem Affenzahn, der schnellste
Stern mit einem Tempo von 18 Millionen Kilometern
pro Stunde.
Alle 15 Jahre hat er die Runde um, ja um Sagittarius
A* gemacht.
So wurde das Schwarze Loch in der Mitte unserer
Galaxie nämlich gefunden, durch die Beobachtung
der Sterne.
Und so verhält es sich auch mit der Galaxie
Messier 87.
In ihrer Mitte ist ein riesiges supermassereiches
Schwarzes Loch mit sechs Milliarden Sonnenmassen.
Und das ist das Bild dieses Schwarzen Loches
und es sieht genuaso aus, wie erwartet.
Zwar ist diese Galaxie mit mehr als 50 Milionen
Lichtjahren viel weiter entfernt als das Schwarze
Loch im Zentrum unserer Milchstrasse, aber
eben leichter beobachtbar, da der Blick auf
das Zentrum der Galaxie relativ frei ist.
Schon 1918 wurde ein Jet aus dem Zentrum der
Galaxie beobachtet, der eben auf ein aktives
Schwarzes Loch schließen läßt.
Wenn wir jetzt also das erste Bild eines Schwarzen
Loches sehen, dann sehen wir direkt die Wirkung
der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie, eine
unglaublich starke Wirkung der Krümmung von
Raum und Zeit.
Das was wir in Form der ersten Gravitationswellen
hier auf der Erde nur ganz schwach gemessen
haben, die Raumzeitkrümmung ist dort gigantisch.
Und es ist wirklich unglaublich.
Zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte der Menschheit
sehen wir ein Schwarzes Loch.
Und wir sehen die heiße Akkretionsscheibe
um das Loch herum, in die die Materie stürzt,
durch eine Geschwindigkeit von etwa 3,6 Millionen
Kilometer pro Stunde unglaublich aufgeheizt
wird und deshalb so hell leuchtet.
100 Milliarden Kilometer Durchmesser hat der
Schwarze Schatten in der Mitte, der Ereignishorizont
des Schwarzen Loches, der alles Licht und
alle Materie hinter sich verschwinden läßt.
Anton Zensus, Direktor am MPIfR and Vorsitzender
des EHT-Leitungsgremiums: “Unsere Ergebnisse
ermöglichen uns zum ersten Mal einen klaren
Blick auf ein supermassereiches schwarzes
Loch und sie markieren einen wichtigen Meilenstein
für unser Verständnis der fundamentalen
Prozesse, die die Bildung und die Entwicklung
von Galaxien im Universum bestimmen.
Es ist besonders bemerkenswert, dass wir es
in diesem Projekt geschafft haben, astronomische
Beobachtungen und theoretische Interpretation
schneller als erwartet zum erhofften Erfolg
zu bringen”, Das wirklich bahnbrechende
ist hier auch, dass die Vorhersagen, wie dies
Bild aussehen würde, genau getroffen würden.
Das ist wirklich der absolute Hammer.
Wir werden uns sicher noch öfter mit diesem
Thema befassen.
Auch Doktor Whatson hat das erste Bild eines
Schwarzen Loches heute zum Thema.
Draufklicken, anschauen und Doktor Whatson
natürlich abonnieren.